die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris einen schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen dem blick auf den
sport gibt es von norbert lehmann
und wir schauen ausführlich hier drauf
fragestunde für den neuen erstmals
stellt sich kanzler scholz im bundestag
den abgeordneten
im schlecht ja oder nein bundespräsident
steinmeier diskutiert kontrovers mit
bürgern und wissenschaftlern während
draußen das omikron problem weiter fahrt
aufnimmt
und problemfall schädlingsbekämpfung ein
neuer pestizid atlas zeigt die folgen
der giftstoffe für mensch und umwelt auf
es ist eines der highlights im bundestag
wenn der kanzler dort rede und antwort
steht das ist in der regel dreimal
jährlich so heute gab es die erste
regierungsbefragung von olaf scholz
allerdings fiel um den umgang mit der
pandemie
der kanzler betonte noch einmal dass er
für eine impfpflicht für alle über 18
jährigen sei nicole diekmann berichtet
zu beginn die afg mit einem eklat die
frage der korona pandemie entschuldigung
herr kanzler jetzt unterbreche ist sie
weil sie alle liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wissen dass das eine politische
aktion ist die wir hier in diesem hause
nicht dulden klare worte der bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas die fdp muss
wieder einpacken inhaltlich aber bleibt
sie bei ihrer linie der bundesregierung
sagt dass bei einer gewissen anzahl von
impfungen ein fall einer schwere
nebenwirkung auftritt meine frage an sie
wären sind sie sich dessen bewusst sie
verwirrend die bürgern und bürger dieses
landes und das einzige was daran gut es
ist dass sie damit keinen erfolg haben
es sind jetzt milliarden bürgern und
bürger der ganzen welt geimpft worden es
ist die große mehrheit der bürger
naumburger und es ist etwas das sehr gut
gegangen ist die union neu in der
opposition versucht die ampel vor sich
herzutreiben ein guter anlass die
impfpflicht die ampel parteien setzen
auf fraktionsübergreifende
gruppenanträge nicht nur cdu und csu
vermuten als grund dahinter die
uneinigkeit zwischen spd grünen und fdp
wie begründen sie dann als
bundesregierung dass sie eine
masernimpfung da waren sie auch
beteiligt hier eben nicht in einer
offenen gruppenantrags bestimmten
abstimmung machen ich bin dafür das zu
machen ich finde das sollte aber eine
entscheidung sein die auf diese weise
zustande kommt dass das aus anträgen aus
dem deutschen bundestag entsteht weil
das der sache angemessen ist corona die
impfpflicht große themen aber nicht die
einzigen scholz bekräftigte den
atomausstieg und zeigt sich besorgt ob
des russischen truppen auf maß an der
ukrainischen grenze also hart angefasst
wird er in seiner ersten befragung als
kanzler nicht
im bundestag soll dann also die
entscheidung gefällt werden ob und wenn
ja was ist für eine impfpflicht geben
wird für alle über 18 jährigen etwa nur
für ältere menschen oder doch gar keine
weil das thema so umstritten ist hat
bundespräsident steinmeier heute dazu
mit menschen gesprochen die für und
gegen das impfen sind thomas reichert
hat die diskussion verfolgt
schloss bellevue großer saal großer
abstand
es wird ein gespräch im kammerton aber
mit position die manchmal so weit
auseinander liegen wie die orte von
denen aus einige der teilnehmer
zugeschaltet sind brauchen wir eine
impfpflicht oder brauchen wir sie nicht
eine solch außerordentliche maßnahme
stellt unseren staat darin eine
außerordentliche pflicht vor seinen
bürgerinnen und bürgern kurz gesagt
impfpflicht
bedeutet debatten pflicht steinmeier hat
impfbefürworter eingeladen und im
skeptiker 60 bis 70 prozent der bislang
ungeliebten will sich weiter nicht
impfen lassen die meisten aus angst
vor wirksam medizinische intervention
dagegen verweisen impfbefürworter in der
runde darauf dass nebenwirkungen extrem
selten seien und es gehe auch um den
schutz anderer um einen solidarbeitrag
ich möchte natürlich auch meine sozialen
kontakte und meine familie davor
schützen insofern ist es für mich
einfach unglaublich starke bedeutung gm
zu sein ich habe ein bisschen ein
problem an der stelle mit dem begriff
solidarbeitrag denn es ist ja so dass
auch vollständig geimpfte das sogar
gewusst hatte es muss weiter gehen
können ja aber schwächer steinmeier
versucht zu moderieren will zuhören
gerade bei der stadt die impfpflicht die
viele nun fordern lange ausgeschlossen
habe nur einmal wird er deutlich es gibt
menschen die sagen wir haben in
deutschland eine corona diktatur
meine damen und herren das ist
bösartiger unfug der bundespräsident
schreibe keine gesetze betont steinmeier
und scheint fast erleichtert schon das
gespräch über die impfpflicht was
schwierig genug
blicken wir auf die korona zahlen so
wird ein neuer höchstwert in deutschland
gemeldet zum ersten mal gibt es laut lka
mehr als 80.000 neue infektionen an
einem tag
384 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage in sident steigt auf 4 107,5 auch
um ikon bereitet sich aus gemeldet
werden insgesamt gut 118 1000 fälle das
sind rund 17.000 mehr als am vortag drei
schipanski über den stand der dinge
sie suchen und sie finden mehr denn je
deutschland sieht rot bremen für die
inzidenz liste der bundesländer an fast
1300 gefolgt von berlin hausarzt malik
bücher pustet in seiner praxis und
schöneberg und testet auch aber lange
ist das nicht mehr zu schaffen
wir sind an der grenze von dem was wir
leisten können vom labor her und wenn
die zahlen sich verdoppeln und nächste
woche ja auch nochmal das doppelte an
menschen an vom den test haben wollen
dann werden wir die hände geben und
werden die texte nicht mehr durchführen
können bundesweit hat sich die inzidenz
in den vergangenen wochen verdoppelt auf
jetzt 4 107 5 und da kommt noch mehr die
zahl der neuinfektionen hat den
bisherigen höchststand vom november
vergangenen jahres inzwischen
übertroffen über 80.000 so sieht
exponentielles wachstum aus auf den
intensivstationen hingegen keine
mikrowelle im gegenteil da ist die zahl
seit mitte dezember kontinuierlich ab
verliert corona dank omikron seinen
schrecken ich würde es für falsch halten
jetzt zu sagen wir lassen die omikron
welle durchlaufen erstens weil wir
fürchten müssen um unsere kritische
infrastruktur zweitens weil die
belastungen gesundheitswesen dazu führen
wird dass wir dann auch andere patienten
nicht mehr gut versorgen können andere
erkrankungen wie herzinfarkt und
schlaganfall auch unfälle machen leider
keine pause in der zeit in niedersachsen
ist omikron mit 85 prozent bereits die
vorherrschende variante deshalb gilt
dort ab heute für die kritische
infrastruktur wie not und
rettungsdienste erlaubt ist jetzt die 60
stunden woche das personal was schon
mehr als zwei jahre belastet ist durch
die pandemie belasten wir noch weiter
durch eine ausweitung von arbeitszeit
grenzen halten wir nicht für gut omikron
markt glimpflicher verlaufen es zu
unterschätzen aber könnte in einer
schmerzhaften erkenntnis enden
jetzt ein urteil zum lockdown im
frühjahr 2020 geschäfte mussten daher
von heute auf morgen schließen während
die miete weiter lief es kam aber ein
anspruch auf mietminderung bestehen das
entschied der bundesgerichtshof
im musterfall ging es um eine filiale
eines textildiscounters am erzgebirge
hier wie anderswo sei allerdings kann
eine pauschale regelung möglich befand
der bgh bei jedem einzelfall müssten die
besonderen umstände berücksichtigt
werden
zum ersten mal seit mehr als zwei jahren
ist der nato russland rat wieder
zusammengekommen eine plattform um
spannungen ab und vertrauen aufzubauen
vor dem hintergrund der ukraine krise
besteht redebedarf auf beiden seiten
denn russland hat zehntausende soldaten
an der grenze zur ukraine stationiert
die nato fürchtet einen einmarsch ins
land moskau streitet das ab gleichzeitig
fordert russland dass die nato keine
weiteren länder im osten aufnimmt
und das treffen des nato russland rates
hat anne gellinek für uns beobachtet
alle ist es gut oder schlecht gelaufen
die tatsache dass das gespräch
stattgefunden hat das 30 nato länder und
russland sich vier stunden lang ziemlich
deutlich gegenseitig die meinung gesagt
haben ist erstmal ein positives zeichen
die nato hat russland eingeladen an
weiteren treffen teilzunehmen zur um
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen zu
besprechen also wer hält wo welche
übungen habe abwehr bewegt truppen auch
über rüstungskontrolle könnte dort
geredet werden russland hat dem heute
noch nicht zugestimmt aber es hat die
einladung zum dialog auch nicht
ausgeschlagen inhaltlich aber und das
ist der teil der schlecht gelaufen ist
sind sich die beiden seiten überhaupt
nicht näher gekommen russland hat nicht
reagiert auf die appelle des westens
seine truppen von der ukrainischen
grenze abzuziehen und die nato hat rund
werk die russischen forderungen nach
einem stopp der nato osterweiterung
abgelehnt hier sind die gräben also noch
sehr tief dennoch glaube ich gibt es
heute abend eine kleine chance auf eine
wiederaufnahme des dialogs
vielen dank für diese einschätzung anne
gellinek
die bundeswehr soll ihren einsatz gegen
den es im irak fortsetzen mit rund 500
soldaten und soldatinnen
das hat heute das ampel kabinett
beschlossen die lage vor ort sei wegen
der fortwährenden bedrohung durch den
ers angespannt einsätze in syrien
schließt das mandat aus die bundeswehr
ist seit 2005 10 im irak stationiert und
bildet dort streitkräfte aus beschließen
muss das mandat macht der bundestag
die kinder sind traumatisiert die
ermittelnden erschüttert angesichts der
fälle sexualisierter gewalt im netzwerk
bergisch gladbach die tatverdächtigen
kommen aus allen gesellschaftsschichten
die ermittlungen waren ins rollen
gekommen nachdem ein fall in bergisch
gladbach aufgedeckt wurde dabei kann man
immer mehr verdächtigen auf die spur
jetzt wurden die ermittlungen dazu
beendet über das ergebnis berichtet dort
habe sie bilanzieren den schrecken 65
kinder das jüngste erst drei monate alt
missbraucht immer wieder vom eigenen
vater vom onkel bis die sonderermittler
der polizei köln das aufdecken
deswegen sage ich ausdrücklich heute ist
kein grund zum feiern
trotz der 65 betreuten kinder und der
vielen tatverdächtigen die wir ermitteln
konnten dafür ist das leid das wir
aufgedeckt haben viel zu groß der
missbrauchs komplex bergisch gladbach
ist weit verzweigt
439 tatverdächtige 27 festnahmen 13
verurteilungen bis jetzt die
ermittlungen dabei äußerst aufwendig und
äußerst belastend bilder die brutale
vergewaltigungen zeigen und kinder die
um ihre verhafteten väter weinen
für mich war erschreckend dass die
kinder die dieses unbeschreibliche für
uns unbeschreibliche leid erlebt haben
aber nach ihren peinigern gerufen haben
auch wenn die sonderermittlungsgruppe
nun aufgelöst wird ermittelt wird weiter
es gibt und ausgewertete material und es
gibt neues
wir erleben es jetzt dass wir von
unbeteiligten die aufmerksame
beobachtung machen mehr hinweise
bekommen als in der vergangenheit die
täter von bergisch gladbach haben hohe
freiheitsstrafen erhalten und das thema
kindesmissbrauch neue aufmerksamkeit
die zahl der organspenden in deutschland
ist trotz der pandemie stabil geblieben
das gab die deutsche stiftung
organtransplantation bekannt insgesamt
haben letztes jahr 933 mensch mindestens
eines ihrer organe gespendet am
häufigsten waren es nieren die stiftung
gehört einem verbund aus acht
europäischen ländern an mehr als 2800
patientinnen und patienten konnte so 20
21 geholfen werden
in die usa denn da liefern sich
demokraten und republikaner einen
erbitterten streit um das wahlrecht in
mehreren republikanischen bundesstaaten
wurden die gesetze so geändert dass
schwarzen und anderen minderheiten die
er demokratisch wählen das wählen
erschwert werde so der vorwurf der
demokraten us-präsident beiden von dazu
jetzt deutliche worte er will die
einschränkung des wahlrechts mit einem
bundesgesetz verhindern wenn der
medaille
seit der us-wahl ende 2020 haben 19
republikanisch regierten bundesstaaten
wahlgesetze beschlossen die das wählen
angeblich hier sicherer machen sollen
unter anderem werden anzahl und
öffnungszeiten von stimmzettel
briefkästen beschränkt außerdem
strengere identitätskontrollen
vermeintliche kleinigkeiten die aber aus
sicht der demokraten vor allem
minderheiten diskriminieren deshalb
fordert joe biden schon lange eine
bundesweite wahlrechtsreform um die
stimmabgabe anzugleichen und zu
erleichtern in georgia nun sein
flammender appell
wählen wir demokratie anstelle von
autokratie licht überschatten
gerechtigkeit über ungerechtigkeit ich
weiß wo ich stehe
joe biden will neue bundesweite regeln
beschließen an die sich dann auch alle
staaten halten müssen bisher können
republikaner durch verfahrenstricks eine
fristgerechte abstimmung verhindern etwa
durch den sogenannten filibuster
senatoren können reden solange sie
möchten der us präsident will das ändern
die republikaner nicht
es geht hier doch gar nicht ums
wahlsystem sondern um macht es gibt
keine anstrengung das wählen von
minderheiten zu unterdrücken sie
existiert nicht
eine bundesweite wahlrechtsreform wäre
also erst dann realistisch wenn es joe
biden zunächst gelänge die filibuster
regel zu ändern da das aber selbst von
demokratischen senatoren kritisch
gesehen wird ist es fraglich ob der
präsident damit erfolg haben kann er
wird also weiterhin erbittert geführt
der kampf um ein gerechteres und
faireres wahlsystem
und nun zum unwort des jahres eine jury
aus sprachen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern hat wieder entschieden
ich würd 20 21 lautet es push back also
das zurückdrängen von flüchtlingen an
grenzen seit 30 jahren wird das gremium
einen begriff der als unangemessen
eingestuft wird dazu gab es diesmal etwa
450 vorschläge auf platz zwei landete
das wort sprach polizei
so viele pflanzenschutzmittel in der
landwirtschaft für mensch und natur kann
das gravierende folgen haben trotzdem
kommen sie massenweise zum einsatz wie
der neue pestizid atlas zeigt
vorgestellt hat in die heinrich böll
stiftung und die
umweltschutz-organisation bnd in
deutschland etwas spritzen bauern und
winzerinnen fast so viel wie vor 20
jahren am meisten werden hierzulande
behandelt danach kommen wein und hoffen
dabei bleiben die pestizide oft nicht
auf den feldern wo sie ausgebracht
werden sondern landen auch in der
umliegenden natur im grundwasser oder in
unserem essen so die kritik vor allem
aber sind sie gift für die biologische
vielfalt markus groß berichtet
winterzeit ist rebschnitt zeit
jungwinzer maxiq macht sich ans werk
vier hektar bewirtschaftet er an der
badischen bergstraße wein ist sehr
anfällig gegen die pilzkrankheit mehltau
muss oft behandelt werden jahrelang hat
er auf chemie gesetzt doch jetzt stellte
er auf bochum die weine gibt keine
rückstände und öko weinbau wird eben ich
sage da auf herbizide spricht
unkrautvernichter verzichtet und auch
auf insektizid also insekten schädigen
mit der mittel und dadurch erhoffe ich
mir einfach in der bändigen weinberg und
mehr biodiversität und mehr insekten die
gefahr für das ökosystem kommt aus dem
sprühen pestizide chemisch-synthetische
mittel gegen unkräuter pilze und
schadinsekten
durchschnittlich 30.000 tonnen dieser
acker gifte kommen jährlich auf
deutschlands felder schädigen dabei
nützliche insekten wie bienen belasten
das grundwasser der pestizideinsatz
umstritten doch für den bauernverband
derzeit noch notwendig pflanzenschutz
sichert erträge und ernten ab und
sichert auch qualitäten ab und wir haben
schon in der deutschen landwirtschaft
den einsatz von pflanzenschutzmitteln
seit den 90er jahren halbiert aber ein
völliger ausstieg ist keine realistische
option max jetzt rückt dem pilz nun mit
backpulver kupfer und schwefel zu leibe
doch diese stoffe wirken nicht so stark
können zudem vom regen ausgewaschen
werden zu lassen sondern wir jetzt 2021
war waren dann doch drei bis vier
behandlungen mehr nötig als es im
konventionellen weinbau gewesen wäre der
öko winzer setzt darauf dass seine
kunden für den verzicht auf juni einen
höheren preis akzeptieren eine rechnung
die im prinzip für alle lebensmittel
gilt für max ist das auch ein beitrag
zum naturschutz
jetzt am sport die olympischen
winterspiele in peking gerne noch 23
tage den ja viel passieren kann vor
allem in sachen corona trotz eines
strengen sicherheitskonzepts für die
einreisenden sportler betreuer und
journalisten die angst der chinesen vor
der verbreitung von omikron ist groß
diese kinder werden für zwei wochen in
quarantäne gebracht ohne eltern mehr als
4000 grund und mittelschüler weil an
ihrer schule in der provinz rennen
einige positiv getestet wurden extreme
maßnahmen die die angst der chinesen vor
einer ausbreitung der omicron variante
kurz vor den winterspielen zeigt in die
entchen der nachbarstadt von peking
wurden stadtteile abgeriegelt weil es
einige dutzend unfälle gab alle 14
millionen einwohner wurden getestet der
öffentliche nahverkehr nach peking
eingestellt
in chinas hauptstadt sind die ersten
olympia teilnehmer angekommen und werden
in solchen hotels von der bevölkerung
abgeschottet nur mit speziellen bussen
und taxis dürfen sie sich zu den
olympischen stätten bewegen die krone
angst geht so weit dass im
lokalfernsehen gewarnt wird bei unfällen
von olympia fahrzeugen keine erste hilfe
zu leisten sondern auch profis zu warten
dabei sollen olympische spiele ein fest
der begegnungen sein
zum biathlon weltcup in ruhpolding beste
deutsche beim frauen sprint franziska
hildebrand auf platz 17 ja die
negativserie der biathletinnen setzt
sich fort und bei den männern fällt
ausgerechnet johannes kühn als bester
deutscher morgen aus wien krone
beim training am vormittag lautet das
motto wir stehen das gemeinsam durch und
gehen doch irgendwie auf abstand der
positive kroner test von johannes kühn
hat das team erschüttert kühlen derzeit
in quarantäne
nach den neuen isolations richtlinien
rechnen wieder mit dass er wolle auch
gewusst hat ist nach sieben tagen mit
einem negativen test sich dann frei
testen kann
ansonsten gibt es aus ruhpolding wenig
positives zu berichten bei einem sprint
der frauen überzeugen andere allen voran
die siegerinnen aus schweden elvira
ölberg beste deutsche heute beim
schlechtesten sprint in diesem winter
franziska hildebrand als siebzehnter
denise herrmann ist von ihrer
olympia-form noch weit entfernt landet
nach zwei schießfehlern auf rang 24
schauen wir mal was die männer morgen
hinkriegen des sprints zehn kilometer ab
14.15 live bei uns im zdf
und jetzt haben wir noch die lotto zeit
für sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 10 16 32
33 38 48 die superzahl ist die vier
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
das wetter bleibt meist ruhig und
teilweise auch sonnig mehr dazu gleich
von ist in tully im heute journal um
21.45 spricht christian sievers mit dem
notebook in reise führt aliens
stoltenberg auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
jeden tag kommen kunden zu mir die
apotheke und klagen über durchfall
bauchschmerzen blähungen was ich da
empfehle retina pro warum weiß wirkt
guidea pro wirksamkeit klinisch belegt
schon gewusst bereits seit 1986 setzt
frau schoss pflanzlich basierten
wirkstoffe aktuell beispielsweise aus
raps oder oliven die kraftvoll beim
reinigen helfen forsch für ein zuhause
zum wohlfühlen
übrigens frosch flaschen bestehen aus
100 prozent plus tick davon 50 prozent
aus dem gelben sack das hält plastik im
kreislauf und spart co2 frosch für
aktiven klimaschutz
[Musik]
entdecken sie das neue wohngefühl dies
bei marina das jetzt versandkostenfrei
bestellen
[Musik]
weil mir meine familie am herzen habe
ich mein leben einem thema gewesen
unserem bakterien millionen von leben
beeinflussen uns und unser lebt mit
führenden wissenschaftlern haben wir das
geheimnis dieser bakterien entschließen
so entstand am new york heute die nummer
eins in deutschlands apotheker fragen
sie nach antibiotika
gerade jetzt in der kalten jahreszeit
wir sind technisch weiter als in den
80ern und was ist mit ihrer geldanlage
hallo es ist zeit geld anlage neu zu
denken diesem funktelefon mit unseren
investmentfonds holen sie ihre
geldanlage ins heute
[Musik]
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der hohen
luftdruck bleibt uns noch erhalten und
auf der ostseite kommen durchaus mal
kompakte wolken mit das wird schon in
der kommenden nacht der fall sein kann
durchaus mal etwas regen rausfallen oder
einige flocken und wenn das der fall ist
wird es glatt auf den straßen im
südwesten klart es auf die temperaturen
sinken an den alpen bis auf minus elf
grad 5 grad in schleswig-holstein ja
morgen gibt es nach nordosten hin viele
wolken ansonsten im südwesten viel
sonnenschein auch an den alpen ein
herrlicher tag und das bei höchsten
temperaturen bis minus ein grad im
vogtland und 8 grad entlang der küsten
die kommenden tage
sonne nebel nebel otto setzt sich fort
nur wenig regen gibt es temperaturen
null bis acht grad damit ein schöner
abend